Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be a breakdown of the trailer and I’ve
also got some news about the villains in X-Men
Apocalypse.
Besides the obvious one.
This is also going to be my bonus Marvel video
this week.
If you’re just now finding me I do bonus
Marvel videos every Tuesday, be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave me suggestion
for future bonus Marvel vids to do in the
future.
In case you didn’t know, It’s coming May
23 in the US and May 22nd in the UK.
So pretty much all of us will get to see it
at the same time.
Let’s get going, I’m really just going
to focus on the new stuff in the trailer,
but since I haven’t done an X-Men video
since the first trailer, that’s a lot.
So right off the bat they’re dropping the
Time Travel bomb.
They’d implied this was happening in all
the trailers, Wolverine being sent back to
rally Professor X and the X-Men against Bolivar
Trask.
The voice over explains why the Sentinels
are bad for everyone and we get a better look
at their ships.
We saw that preview clip from the mtv movie
awards where they were dropping out of them
into battle.
They remind me a lot of the way the Chitauri
living ships functioned in Avengers, just
like troop ships.
I’m really curious to see how they explain
both versions of Professor X talking to each
other psychically across time.
It’s an awesome visual, but it’s going
to have to jump through a few logic hoops
based on mutant abilities in
the future.
We see Wolverine going around and grabbing
Beast, who for some reason isn’t full on
Blue, unless he’s mystique in disguise.
Bryan Singer is really good at making ensemble
films and thrillers, and I kind of think of
Days of Future Past as a Time Travel Political
Thriller with Mutants and Machines instead
of James Bond.
They show Magneto in prison and Mystique not
with him, so clearly something went wrong
after the events of the last movie.
I’m even more confused about the timeline
and Beast’s appearance now.
We finally get the big Quicksilver Intro.
The funny part is that they’re going to
use him to break his father, Magneto out of
the Pentagon prison.
Love that Nixon poster in the background of
his home.
The breakout scene is also a little confusing,
I loved Xavier punching Magneto, but why can
he walk, when he was crippled during the last
movie.
So many questions.
They’re really laying it on thick here with
the Magneto Baseball stadium effect.
They wanted to top that levitation scene from
the first movie.
I think this is kind of an absurd way to do
it, but I’ll wait till I see it in the context
of the story to judge.
Peter Dinklage is going to be epic as Boliver
Trask, just watch him on Game of Thrones if
you don’t believe me.
The design of the 70s sentinels is pretty
cool, but the future ones are really trippy.
I can’t wait to see the rest of what the
future looks like.
The ships and tech look amazing.
We see bone claws Wolverine, like in the post
credits scene from The Wolverine movie last
year.
In the promo images of future wolverine we
saw the adamantium claws, so I wonder if they
just did that wrong, or if changing the past
gives future wolverine his normal claws back.
More timeline questions.
The final scene is also really awesome.
I just love that Wolverine would tell someone
flat out what their future was.
Most people would pause to consider the ramifications,
but Wolverine is just like Fuck Spoilers dude,
you totally die.
So the big news right now about X-Men Apocalypse,
the spiritual sequel to Days of Future Past
is that Mister Sinister will be in the movie
and Apocalypse of course.
But Mister Sinister will be like the Loki
of the movie.
As in the X-Men will be fighting him for most
of the movie before Apocalypse steps out of
the shadows.
I think of him as being Fox’s version of
Thanos.
They’re the two biggest villains you could
possibly use, so neither studio wants to roll
them out too soon.
That’s why it’s taken so many Marvel movies
to get to Thanos.
There’s no word on what either Sinister
or Apocalypse will look like, but the story
will loosely be based on the Age of Apocalypse
storyline and supposedly they’re bringing
back Nightcrawler and Gambit.
Here’s a quick breakdown of how you get
from Days of Future Past in the 70s to Age
of Apocalypse in the 80s.
In Days of Future Past the mutants are driven
to extinction, then attempt time travel as
a way to change the future.
So even if they’re only a little successful
in changing what happens with the sentinels,
they’ve created a whole new timeline.
And the beauty of X-Men stories is that no
matter what you do, the outcome doesn’t
change too much.
So instead of being super happy hug time,
the new future created in Days of Future Past
is still awful, it’s just overrun with minions
of Apocalypse, primarily Mister Sinister.
It’s like you swing from Humans dominating
Mutants to Evil Mutants dominating Humans
and Mutants.
So it’s almost a worse future.
Since Bryan Singer said the plot would only
loosely be based on Age of Apocalypse, we’ll
have to wait for more information about the
cast to guess what they’ll change.
But Channing Tatum did confirm he was in talks
to play Gambit and if they’re bringing Nightcrawler
back they could shuffle the cast depending
on who dies during Days of Future Past.
So I’ll do a future video for Apocalypse
at some point, but my next Days of Future
Past video will probably be the review of
the movie when it comes out.
Feel free to suggest future Marvel bonus videos
for me to do.
And heads up, I’m posting Agents of SHIELD
later tonight, super late.
Patton Oswalt was on and he was amazing.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
You can click here to watch it, I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I upload it.
And click here to learn more about Captain
America 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!